you know what I'm gonna bring this up
because I just gotta be real about my
feelings because I'm human
hi what's up everybody here we have Maya
Maya what are you sitting on currently
what are you what do you what do you
want what do we what are we doing
yeah she has a mini microphone oh she
doesn't want to be interviewed she's
camera shy
behind me oh it's my beautiful wife any
other cat you want to be interviewed no
picnic no comment behind me are four
gigantic boxes actually I see it's five
one two three four and five over there
and these boxes inside are the missing
final pieces to our living room dining
room kitchen furniture I also purchased
this from a Instagram head so I kept
seeing this ad pop up of this this
transformer table which is not sponsored
but I wish because it was kind of crazy
but yeah like it's kind of cool because
it goes from like two seater table or
you're gonna one person table to up to
12 people so then like we can like
extend the table for whatever we have
yeah these are the final big pieces for
this downstairs I was just telling Casey
I'm like maybe maybe I shouldn't buy
rugs and maybe you don't look good
like just with the floor itself I like
the the wood floors we have and it's
really about who your neighbor is having
their backyards worked on so in case you
guys are hearing true I'm kind of
jealous of them I'm lying
I want my backyard done - yeah their
elbows on that's gonna be working on her
backyard and he has my cousin son
whatever there's a family member in
their home that has like an autoimmune
disease so he can't really expose
himself out to continue to work in his
landscaping business
so that's why we're on hold but
neighbors are like screw that we're
getting our stuff done and their
contractors are like screw that we're
getting money yep anyway I'm excited do
you guys have served us well thank you
thank you thank you Marie condo-style
thank you
and you guys will be put into storage
now storage is going upstairs all right
upstairs for whenever we want to be pigs
upstairs I want to be pigs everywhere we
go in this house because I like being
lazy my own house now it looks like the
music studio like it looks like a
musician's how I like it
yes you are you're jamming
[Music]
they like that noise I thought haven't
done it
I know we've moved it from there to here
because I was mopping the floors earlier
and then I bought this a long time ago
for this project that could good like
you're in a half snowman and I spilt and
then I forgot that I had it and then I
bought it again to do this we're gonna
do it two times we said we don't want
all rights do it
transform tables let's go yeah true not
sponsored
[Music]
check it out there's like the fully
extended version of it it's so cool man
this table is awesome because here's a
coffee table right and then inside the
coffee table we have all the extra
panels that we can put for the big table
and then inside of the bench there all
these extra panels so we can like place
them on top this is like for the for
kings and queens yeah and I shall sit on
the ends of the table
Danya like this every dinner really oh
my god yeah it's kind of amazing though
honestly when I first bought this I'm
like I don't know if it'll actually been
our tiny home so I it's a lot bigger
than I expected it to be and
surprisingly actually fits in this space
yeah that's the part that I mean like I
didn't think you would even fit in the
space but yeah it's pretty cool and I
love how small he gets to like like
literally I'm only pulled out it was
just like a little yeah do you wanna
think we're gonna put it together hold
on so we ready no the smallest version
of the bench is right there
then all we got to do the tables
and then that's like a tiny little desk
but you know what sucks
they actually delivered it slightly
damaged so we noticed here it's kind of
messed up so I'm gonna call them and see
what we can do about this
because this is not acceptable other
than that yeah what work is really
really it's really nice actually
you know that's from Canada acacia wood
maybe Keisha wood I don't have that in
Minecraft I don't know
acacia yeah I think that's a pronounced
I don't know it's builds a se oh yeah
like that
let's go like a copy ah this is so nice
so how big are we gonna actually leave
it I mean two minutes two panels two of
those yeah but what do you think should
we get rugs or leave it cuz I don't know
like I thought it might be kind of cool
to just see it on top of just the wood
floor like gonna take it as minimal
that's right yeah just keep it the way
it looks but then the more I'm looking
at it I think it kind of bugs me how
it's light wood on light wood so if we
can like break that up with a nice rug I
think I might end up doing it I don't
know maybe yeah but maybe I'm being too
picky but yeah like the light wood on
the light wood I'm not really a gigantic
fan of cuz that piece over there is a
dark wood so maybe if I would have
gotten the dark wood version it wouldn't
bug me that much but I really needed
that like it makes you feel gloom yeah
that's true and I love like the colors
you chose and the lighter wood now and
the white cabinets over in the kitchen
like it
you know I was this close and ordering
the white version of this instead but
then I don't know do you think now I
mean now that we have this here in place
imagine it white and in the rest of the
house you might be too much white that's
why I ended up going with this cuz I'm
like this is kind of nice I like this
we'll see what happens I'll just live
with it without rugs for now and then
see if we've changed my mind later what
do you think that do you like it just
one Oh what I think I like it what I
know what you mean like you don't want
to be too matchy-matchy with like what
in like wood but I don't like how like
everything else is very eclectic and the
one thing we don't have mixed in yet
it's like some minimalism
well the blinds are I think the buyer
I'm a minimalistic right but I just like
a nice you know simple and complex yeah
yeah because then we have like loudness
their loudness with the patterns a bit
and yeah I don't know we'll see I'm
really happy with this stuff I love the
fact that we can just fully extend it
and we can eat like kings and queens or
study buddy yeah JT new study days you
haven't won this thing I'm just betting
on [ __ ] small this version of it I
feel like one laptop might figure sure
that's it but yeah we could just put one
panel maybe yeah that'd be I think it's
that big I'm not sure we got it let's
put panels okay so this is what we got
going on so we decided to test out the
placement testing out the sleep ability
what do you want to sleep it's pretty
hard oh my gosh you're like Isaac you
wanted to sleep on top of his dresser
then you have this nice comfy couch and
we had visitors I mean we have an extra
Lansing for the visitors so yeah so I
wanted to see how would it look if it
was this like you know the benches on
this end and then the table like this
and I rather tell you I'm not a fan I
don't like it I don't like the way the
benches are like the way you see it
kinda looks really picnics out so I
think we're gonna end up leaving it this
way like you know that the other way
for me I stretched out exactly like that
way but then now we're looking at how
wide this table is because I didn't
expect it to be like like really really
really wide it makes sense why it is
this white because it's like sturdier
but I don't know like just seeing it in
this space I'm like maybe it's too wide
we tried considering removing the panel
because this is with two panels so then
we tried considering removing a panel
but then that would just be a perfect
square which is it would just really
feel right in this room either right
like it's not enough space for the three
of us to eat with the benches that we
have and if we get like another like the
end chairs and maybe but I don't know
like really like how do I make this work
how do I make this look good because
this is kind of a beefy table but I
don't know do you think it is a PG table
yeah I was actually hoping that it
wouldn't be a beefy table either because
our last table was really beefy you know
like don't like it yeah and then I
thought oh cool this is this seems like
our retainer seems like it should be
alright yeah yeah so kind of beefy maybe
it's the space of the house exactly the
house the space of this house is weird
though I mean we went into this house
knowing though it's weird
yeah it was all kind of one room right
here exactly but yeah but then now with
this here I'm like whoa this is kind of
big thank you org I think yes flipping
it back the other way around the way we
had our going first hopefully the boxes
and then maybe we have to live in it and
kind of feel it out maybe maybe give it
a week's time yeah and see how we like
it don't like it and truth go from there
we can figure out how adjust but look at
that gigantic piece of styrofoam though
I've never seen styrofoam this beefy but
it for a beefy table yeah right yeah and
then look how much styrofoam and trash
was in all the boxes that we just opened
we do we do create a lot of trash when
we move there you create less trash
stop moving I think we're gonna stop me
now I know I like the coffee table yeah
the coffee table is that's what we're
gonna do all the time we're always going
to run a kid I think we are yeah feel
this actually poke some dang there's
kind of different avenues this one's
like softer oh man should we move it I
was kind of looking at it too so we
decided this is the way it's gonna stay
and and then I ended up putting oh oh
yeah
wrong one remember it's on this side you
see there we go oh yeah one day as long
as you live here you're learning but
yeah check it out
I love it our house is like like
practically complete I think at this
point is like pretty close now but yeah
just a few like final touches yeah
chasey now we're talking about it just
now and we decided yes yes to the rug
just here in the living room we're not
gonna do a rug here and then we were
looking at some rugs online and I think
we found one who we like so picture this
with the rug
you know kind of create a like a nice
division yeah so cliff you're literally
one hop away from me - yeah oh and then
we also hung this this Tiki mask that I
got from Hawaii for the very first time
the bathroom yet I don't believe I have
shown you what I've done to the bathroom
and I'll show you right now what do you
guys think
okay so missing this slice we will I
have ordered it and then we're gonna
have finish it up here but for the most
part yeah this is this is what I did
here there's some candles back there
it's like a really nice teal so it kind
of like ties it in with the whole like
teal ish vibes that we got over here and
then also the blue backsplash of the
kitchen I am really happy I'm like I'm
really proud of myself I really like it
I'm really really happy you know what
I'm gonna bring this up because I just
gotta be real about my feelings because
I'm human when we uploaded the video
about the stairs
I avoid the comments because I am
sensitive I guess like I'm human I have
feelings and I kind of like it personal
sometimes for the stairs I was just so
so so proud of the stairs around like I
freaking love it right and I was just so
so happy to share with you guys so
that's the reason why I kind of went in
the comments a bit and I was just like
wow what you guys think and so many of
you loved it you guys were like oh my
god I look so flat it looks amazing and
then so many of you guys were like that
looks ugly look like a grandma
tell us like that's way too busy you
guys you know pick a theme and stick to
it and all this stuff and I was just
like ouch kind of work I appreciate the
ground my house I do feel that way too
but in a good a good way because because
like had old people right to have
experienced a lot in the world have
traveled the world a lot no a lot of
things are eclectic and culture in eight
years sure reminds me of how I feel
internally - oh my god like I like
traveling I like foods from all over the
world
I like are like music we listen to a lot
of jazz yeah we're cultured AF I know I
think it's us to back off no I mean I I
don't want to say like back off no you
guys are entitled to your opinions for
sure I respect that you guys don't like
it you don't like it that's cool I'm
just being real about how I felt when I
read that which was a little bit like
disappointing where I'm like oh yeah but
obviously I can't please everyone like
you know beauty is in the eye of the
beholder like art is subjective
everyone's gonna have their opinions
about it so I understand that it's just
one thing to be logical about it and
then nother thing to be emotional about
it so I'm just sharing you guys the
emotional side of it we're on my
but it's okay I love it I I personally
am happy with it and I'm the one that
has to live here I'm the one that has to
see it every single day and it makes me
happy when I see it so yay
same thing with everything in this
living room and that wallpaper I love
it's so pretty and so vibrant
and I just love how everything is just
tight in like I'm so freaking proud of
myself I love it and then the fact that
you love it too makes me happy so yeah
so now we're gonna eat and enjoy with a
new dining table check this out what are
we eating by the way tacos we found this
taco spot around our area mm-hmm
supporting a local business Mel's
amazing yeah we're about to dig in but
thanks for watching guys please even
though I just shared with you about my
emotions and everything you guys are
more than welcome to leave your opinions
in your comments in this video so I will
be very cautious when looking through it
because I gotta protect my feelings but
please like don't don't hold back like
no I'm not trying to invite the hate I'm
just saying like we're just we just go
and express yourselves like that's the
whole point of this platform is to for
us to connect and for you guys to
express yourselves as well just like how
I'm expressing myself in this video so
yeah
[Music]